le barrage de kakova a donc été ciblé
par des frappes situées dans la région
de Kerson occupé au sud de l'Ukraine il
s'agit de lune des plus grandes
infrastructures de ce type dans le pays
on va tout de suite retrouver à Kiev
Gulliver crag notre correspondant
Gulliver bonjour plusieurs villages ont
déjà été inondés selon les autorités
ukrainiennes et des milliers de
personnes seraient menacées
oui village ou petite ville et un
quartier derrière sonne selon les
autorités régionales de la région de
Herson il faut dire que ce sont des
villages et aussi un quartier derrière
sonne dont beaucoup de personnes sont
déjà parties en réalité parce que c'est
des territoires situés près de la ligne
de front assez souvent
victime de tir de l'artillerie russe qui
est de l'autre côté du fleuve nathaliec
la porte-parole pour les militaires
Ukrainiens dans le sud du pays a dit que
il est possible qu'il y aura un peu
moins de tirs dans les jours qui
viennent puisque les Russes vont être
obligés de quitter leur position sur la
rive sud-est du nerf du fait des
inondations de ce côté là je pense que
les inondations ont fait sur la rive
sud-est pourrait être plus importante
encore mais c'est bien sûr sur la rive
nord-ouest que se situe la ville de
Herson dont une partie apparemment est
déjà inondée des trains d'évacuation
partent des personnes en direction de
mikolaif pour les gens qui doivent
quitter c'est localités et sinon une
information qui vient de tomber c'est
que la compagnie ukrainienne qui gère
les centrales hydroélectriques ou crédit
rennergo je crois que ça s'appelle a dit
que le barrage est irréparable c'était
une station itrue électrique qui générée
de l'électricité pour plus de 3 millions
de foyers alors sur le plan des
infrastructures de l'Ukraine c'est aussi
quelque chose à tenir en compte les
dommages sont très importantes et
Gulliver le président ukrainien veut le
dix meilleurs Zelinski a convoqué son
Conseil de sécurité la présidence
ukrainienne qui accuse Moscou de vouloir
avec cette destruction freinée son
offensive
oui je pense que
l'interprétation de l'interprétation qui
est fait en Ukraine c'est effectivement
que ils l'ont ils ont fait ça pour
freiner l'offensive tes Ukrainiens pour
entreprendre plus difficile d'être
traversé le fleuve pour les obliger à
détourner des ressources vers ce
problème là qui vient de se produire
c'est quelque chose qui avait été évoqué
en octobre dernier si vous vous souvenez
les Russes accusés les Ukrainiens de
vouloir faire sauter le barrage les
Ukrainiens notons qu'il serait
impossible de le faire en fait avec une
requête à longue distance et qu'une
seule manière serait de le faire
exploser en plantant des munitions sur
le barrage eux-mêmes ont remarqué que
c'était le Russe qui contrôlait ce
territoire et que si quelqu'un allait
faire exploser les paroles c'était ça
allait forcément être les Russes et le
fait que les Russes accuser les
Ukrainiens de vouloir le faire les
faisait soupçonner que les Russes le
feraient tout le monde à ce moment-là
était très inquiet mais disait que ni
l'un côté ni l'autre côté ne ferait
quelque chose d'aussi drastique et que
notamment les Russes ne le ferais pas
parce que le barrage affecte aussi
l'alimentation en eau fraîches de la
Crimée et puis mais on périt le
potentiellement la centrale nucléaire
des aporisa qui dépend des eaux du
réservoir derrière le barrage pour ces
systèmes de refroidissement mais là
aujourd'hui les experts nucléaires et
l'autorité qui gère les centrales
nucléaires du crâne rassure en disant
cette centrale ne fonctionne pas il est
occupé les réacteurs sont tous ces temps
pendant qu'ils sont éteints et ingénères
pas l'électricité ils n'ont pas besoin
de grosses quantités d'eau pour se
refroidir alors pour le moment pas
vraiment d'inquiétude à avoir pour la
centrale nucléaire si ce n'est
l'inquiétude générale que de voir que
les Russes apparemment sont capables de
faire des choses aussi irrationnelles et
alors on se demande jusqu'où est-ce
qu'il pourrait aller dans de tel de
telles destruction merci beaucoup
Gulliver crack notre correspondant à
Kiev